before her beauty saw not the Beast but
the radiant face of a handsome young
then he went to the foot of the tower
and called out just as she had rapunzel
rapunzel let down your golden hair
school welcome she went straight to
Hansel opened his shed and cried Hansel
we're safe the old witch is dead their
stories that have been read for
centuries but told for millennia tales
from our ancient past at have outlived
languages and seen many ages of man we
know that these traditions are passed
down from generation to generation by
comparing tales from different cultures
that makes it possible to trace lineages
of common inheritance so as you it's
essentially excavating information about
the past that's been preserved through
the mechanism of inheritance here the
living fossils if you like of these
traditions when the Brothers Grimm
started collecting these fairy tales in
the 19th century vilhelm Grimm suggested
then that these stories might be
thousands of years old but that's a view
that's long been challenged now it seems
they might even out date classical
mythology it was widely believed that
fairy tales were first written down by
sixteenth and seventeenth century
writers but the researchers at
universities in Durham and Lisbon found
some tales were older than the earliest
literary records of the 27th and twenty
sixth centuries BC with one dating back
to the Bronze Age Rumplestiltskin 4,000
years old Beauty and the Beast also
4,000 years old the Smith and the devil
6,000 years old
glenroy Thank You Ravi and the stories
often centered around themes like love
betrayal and hope continue to be
devoured by the children of today
there's a anthropologist who coined the
phrase that we're not homo sapiens we're
home owner ends where narrator people
with Darby our species is one that likes
to tell stories and that's from gossip
and anecdotes to the great tragedies
fairy tales are usually told by an adult
to a child and so it's natural the most
popular stories should stand the test of
time they've nourished the imagination
for thousands of years and they probably
will do for thousands more rigid Suchet
Sky News